hello hello Utah can you hear me
in a round of applause if you can hear
me
there we go please
and Ryan Smith owner of the Utah Jazz
but we have to give it up for this
outfit a one-of-one jacket he's looking
pretty clean up here yeah stand up give
a show look look at jacket y'all
it's amazing what they give you at all
star exactly so I love people that are
incredibly enthusiastic about what they
do and the things that they love and
Ryan is so enthusiastic about Utah you
were telling me what this moment has
felt like for you what has it been like
to see everybody here enjoying your
state
um so first of all it's it's cool how
you doing y'all good
um
it's been incredible I mean this is a
state like that that I think a lot of
people come to but they don't they don't
ever really experience and so it's been
pretty cool to watch people have the
whole Utah experience here and I mean
you see it like it's on but this is what
we we know and love and this is why
we're here like the growth over the last
10 years in this state has been the
fastest in the U.S and there's a reason
for it there's a reason why people are
moving here why they want to be here
um it's a reason for wellness it's a
reason for things they can't get other
places
and um I think the world's seeing that
right now absolutely how many here have
just been enjoying their experience here
in Utah let's go I've loved it I love
seeing the mountains I have loved the
parties it really has been an amazing
experience and I think that for you I
mean you were here in 1993 when Utah
hosted these festivities now you are the
host and also obviously a major part of
the franchise how personal has this
weekend felt I mean that's a little
crazy to think about as like a a kid
like coming to jam session not being
able to go to the game obviously but
like
and then being in this spot like it's
not lost on me or my family I have
little boys and and girls who like
um I hope they have an amazing
experience but but you know the way that
we came in to take over the Jazz and
um everything that's happened it's kind
of been surreal like you don't get your
home team ever if you're lucky enough to
be part of the NBA you just don't get
your home team yeah and so the good news
is I know what that means I know what it
feels like I know the history no one
needs to tell me and I've we all know as
fans what we want to do and
um I think we're on our way absolutely
so you guys obviously uh he works in the
front office with the Jazz but also he
beat Dwyane Wade in a Three-Point
Contest oh man and I think that that
needs some shine 11 to 10 right and no
money balls no no money boss
Dwyane Wade in a Three-Point Contest
what was your preparation like headed
into that well so Dee was taught I mean
there was a lot of smoke going back and
forth on Twitter like D's like he always
says hey I'm not in the gym you're
always in the gym and he was he was
prepping like he was in there he was in
LA I was getting feedback from different
people but when the bell rings like you
got to make shots and I think if we
would have had NBA balls D would have
definitely had me there was like a Delta
between like 10 and 15 16. I shot first
hit 11. I said he's gonna beat me by six
and I mean we were shooting for three
thousand dollars a ball for fight for
the fight for cancer research which is
pretty cool
um but he's a good sport there's not a
lot of upside for him to shoot against
me
um there's only upside for me to shoot
against him and he was awesome but it
what's crazy is it all started because
when we come to Jazz games and he's part
of our ownership group like him and I
just started shooting against each other
yeah in front of the fan and like
um it kind of becomes a thing and then
the NBA caught on and was like hey were
you two Captain the celebrity All-Star
Game into a shoot off and then they
wanted to do three racks and I was like
no if I can get them to five racks then
maybe he'll get tired if I'm a little
more conditioned that was my only hope
and I think my strategy worked and so
kind of just I think the transitive
property of it all doesn't it kind of
mean that you're going to be a future
Hall of Famer if you beat me no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no these
there's only one D way absolutely and by
the way like him getting like
to that next step which looks like this
year like so proud of him he's such a
great human so deserved and he has been
such just a beautiful Ambassador for the
Utah Jazz yeah just how has that
friendship formed and what has he meant
to the franchise look we have a lot of
mutual friends who have known for have
have been apart for a long time and like
helped him or been in business with him
and so when we got together he was
looking at saying hey I want to I want
to have a different role in basketball
um
and and it just we had just taken over
and we said hey if we're if we're ever
going to work with an ex-player or
someone there like how would that look
and then we're like wait
D Wade's an incredible business mind
he's like he he's the homie
incredible
it's Dwayne in Utah because of obviously
everything is done in Miami and he lives
in L.A but if you actually think about
it everything we're trying to do fits
his brand perfect for what we're doing
together and like we were playing Spades
last night him and gav and like me and
Ash and like they took us down so he did
get his win
um but like we're having it's so much
fun it's just so much fun to hang out
and what he loves is like he comes here
and he like gets to get away from it
yeah and that's what this Wellness piece
of Utah is like everyone like first of
all everyone's like Utah's not a large
Market okay so first of all I'm sick of
hearing that okay like I never want to
hear it described as a small Market
again here's why you ready I'm ready
bringing some heat
is everybody ready Utah it's not a small
Market why we're not saying it anymore
okay give us the rundown Ryan okay so
the way they determine market size is
based on televisions and homes
is that really a metric that we're
counting these days
at Bleacher Report I mean come on yeah
you wouldn't exist if that was a metric
that we're doing right yeah so that's a
bad metric first of all second the
reason why people move to Utah is
because they've been living in towers
and they want to get out of the super
cities and actually come and have a yard
and be able to hike and have a dog and a
pool and like do that so they're here to
get away from being stacked on top of
each other and actually spread out yeah
and have a family and do that
the the next biggest thing is like hey
there's no nightlife
oh there was night of this week let me
tell you that were you all out were
y'all yeah yeah
[Music]
that you couldn't get
to all the places you want to get yeah
you know how long it took us to to turn
that up five days
yeah
it's easy
to have nightlife yeah that's not hard
anyone can have nightlife yeah
people are here because they want to go
into the nightlife but they want to come
home and live yeah
right
and then if you look at what we have no
one else has that
no one can build that anyone can do
light no one can do this no one can do
the fastest growing economy no one can
do the lowest unemployment no one can do
that if you were in an economic position
in your world and you come to Utah it is
the highest chance in the U.S that you
are going to move up yeah right the tech
boom that's happened here we have seven
million people to come in and ski in
Salt Lake City are 25 miles away from
Seven world-class ski resorts
right
um we're the most charitable States so
the people are nice yeah now that is
very true every person I've met has been
incredibly kind of and so and then
there's one more thing
40 miles south 40 miles north you have
over 250 000 college kids
which means it's not going away
and so all of that will be here and
that's why we're long on Utah and it's
something that's that's pretty cool and
we got to show that this weekend yes I'm
ready to run through a wall for you too
I already I already like this place but
now I absolutely love it okay speaking
of Utah I know one of your guys is about
to come up but before we focus on Colin
Sexton I do want to focus a little bit
on Lori marketing
Glory fan you guys will be represented
today yeah we
over here
I have loved his journey I just want to
know what did you see in Lori so look I
mean in this position we've been in this
position for two years we brought in
Danny Ainge and
um you know we got Justin zanek as her
GM and we said hey look we need to kind
of retool the the system for the next 10
years that we have an incredible run and
we had to make some hard decisions you
know and Donovan Mitchell and Rudy
gobert and
um Lowry was one that Cleveland didn't
want to give up but there's not many
seven Footers that can shoot like that
and Coach Hardy has put him in an
incredible position for maybe being like
a third option to the the number one
Scout every night that people are coming
out being more physical with them and
he's figured out how to grow every part
of that and it's just beautiful to watch
because it's not like one that's gonna
go away it's like like you saw it when
Euro basking it's what oh yeah it's a
good lesson on what confidence can do
yeah and situation and situation and
um we're excited and so we want we
hopefully can do that with with every
player and including the one that's
about ready to walk on stage right now
absolutely
lock some some young bull for everyone
yes I love it well hey please give it up
a Ryan Smith give it up for the state of
Utah all the fun that you have had so
far this weekend you are Joy I cannot
wait to come back and I'm so excited to
see everything that the Jazz does
absolutely thank you Ryan what's up you
guys on the way up
give it up for Colin Sexton y'all
the jacket game is strong on this stage
I must say
all right Colin whose jacket is better
yours or Ryan
fire fire all right Colin Sexton
everybody hello how you feeling I'm
doing good excited definitely excited to
be here yeah I mean it has to have been
a really amazing experience for you
being able to just have All-Star Weekend
in your state how fun has that been uh
it's been very fun I feel like just
showing the fans what Utah's all about
but also just showing it the people that
uh it's nice out here you should
definitely come back for sure okay who
in here was watching that dunk contest
last night
all right well Colin absolutely was I
have seen the memes I have seen how much
fun you were having from your Vantage
Point how insane is Mac McClung oh man
he's insane especially to get those
dunks first try after
a lot of Misses here and there but to
get it first try each and every time it
was very very impressive yeah okay which
one was most impressive to you I would
say the 540 the 540 was one of the
toughest dunks I know I only did it one
time and for him to do a first try
that's that's the kind of tool okay so
y'all know we have seen Collin Sexton
have some good in-game dunks we had a
moment over bam we had one over but two
would you ever do Duncan chess coming up
um are you into we're putting him on the
spot do y'all want to see him in the
dunk contest
the people are speaking I wouldn't mind
doing it I definitely wouldn't mind
doing it but I would say the creativity
that it takes to to dunk now is a lot
more time and I was just like I don't
know if I want to do that yeah
like those dunks were that we saw
because we know they look fun but
there's just really a level of elite
athleticism that you have to have to
pull those off I would say number one
it's also confidence
um I know you ever want to talk about
the athleticism like you said but also
the confidence to do it and to not worry
about it because at the end of the day
you might miss and if you miss it you
got to make sure you have plans next
playing Plan B okay now if that don't
work then we got to go to something
especially since you're watching the
clock a minute it feels a lot faster
when um you're trying to rush to Duncan
for sure for sure and so when you were
Lido at all star and you know the all
the players kind of have that Nook that
everybody's in just enjoying the
festivities right but earlier in the
night
he won the skills competition oh yeah
definitely we had to give it up for team
Jazz winning the skills competition
[Music]
what was the preparation going into that
the preparation going into it we didn't
have no strategy so we had to figure out
a strategy I know
um Walker he's the one that came up with
the strategy for us okay me and JC was
like bro let's just wing it and then we
knew that wasn't gonna gonna work so uh
Walker definitely came through for us
we're giving I'm giving him his credit
he's the one that came up with the
victory for us okay well vlogger give it
up for Walker Kessler I guess he's he's
why as team job is able to get that W
there because I think I saw JC saying it
was about working smarter not harder
yeah absolutely listen
anything about JC you know he gonna take
the easy way he's gonna try to
especially the first competition I was
like what you doing he was like yeah I
was just warming up I'm like listen we
can't be warming up in this competition
for sure but we won we came up with the
victory what aspect of it was more
difficult than you anticipated it to be
oh
I would say just like going through like
the speed part the first part I would
say just because you have to make
everything
um oh we could tell yeah you have to and
if you if not then you just sit more
time there and I feel like 15 seconds
goes really really quick so yeah okay so
speaking of Jordan Clarkson whenever I
talk to any bad about Jordan they just
talk about how great of a teammate he is
what makes him such a special guy uh
he's just one of those people that comes
in just laughing joking always trying to
have fun but most of all he's he's gonna
come in and be the same person every day
um and that's what we need and that's
what you need on teams where you know a
vet is going to come in and just be the
same person and I change up definitely
okay so we're all looking forward to
tonight one of the things I'm most
excited for is this new All-Star draft
format oh yeah I cannot wait to see who
gets picked so you know at first you
have to pick a reserve and then you pick
a starter if you were a team captain
who's the first Reserve you take off the
board and who's the first starter you
take off the board and you can't say
Lori
I gotta say my guy Larry marketing for
sure
um easy way out that's the easy way out
just because that's my guy but I'm very
excited for him tonight I just can't
wait to to see him participate in the
game I know how much hard work he puts
in each and every day and I see it see
it pay off we've been together in
Cleveland and we're together here so
it's definitely cool to see his success
and see how much he's gotten better uh
just over a year okay so that's the
start of you you pick which Reserve
would you pick first uh I would say I
gotta go with uh Ant-Man he from Atlanta
um that's my guy so you're not from
Gwinnett County oh yeah okay
I went to Pebble Brook okay where'd you
go I went to Pea Ridge
up there in a little bougie area
just a little bit it's all good but
speaking of Lori how have you seen him
continue to grow and just become better
game after game oh man I would say it's
just confidence his confidence has grown
over just a couple months we've been
together you're just starting to see has
a different Swagger about himself he
carries himself a lot different and
um he knows it he's good he's no he's
carrying us right now and
um now he's putting the pieces together
so that we can continue to move forward
let's do it okay let's talk a little bit
about Colin Sexton's game what do y'all
think Wanna Talk About Colin a little
bit
you are an intense and intimidating
Defender we've all seen the videos right
is there a method behind the madness to
to you kind of being animated out there
when you're defending uh not at all I
just try to uh uh just try to go out
there and just play hard whenever I'm
out there and just do what I can
um whether it's playing hard on defense
or diving at the ball whatever whatever
team means I'm gonna do it what do you
want being defended by Colin Sexton to
feel like
I wouldn't feel like you're in a phone
booth and you can't leave that's what I
wanted to feel like I wanted to feel
like it's nowhere for you to go because
I'm in I'm in all sides so I
very clear that you take a lot of pride
in your defense I think in the league
right now that's a little Rare Defense
isn't the thing that people are very
actively working on I think that we can
all agree with that why do you take so
much pride in it uh just because I'm a
competitor I'm definitely very
competitive I don't like being scored on
I don't like someone feeling like they
have their way against me so
um as long as I make the night tough of
course it's the NBA guys gonna make
shots everyone's really good guys
practice but as long as they can leave
tonight but it was a tough night and I
didn't get nothing easy that's all that
matter what has been your toughest
matchup so far in your career I would
say Steph and Kyrie because those two
guys play totally different games Steph
he moves without the ball a lot Kyrie he
has the ball a lot with his dribbles and
fadeaways like those two guys are two of
the most I love playing against just
because I know I gotta
be on my game each and every time I play
them what is the most underrated aspect
of your
most underrated that I can shoot I can
shoot the ball really good it's like I
can shoot y'all
shooter and that's something that a lot
of people don't really see but a lot of
the coaches from other teams our team a
lot of people see around the league
so when they told me that I was going to
be interviewing Colin Sexton I said okay
wait a minute there's one thing I have
to ask about that you've probably been
asked about so many times have you all
seen the video of Colin at the free
throw line in high school his opponent
looks like he's staring at him and he
turns around and just stares him down
have you all seen that
okay show of hands you've seen the video
okay we have some people that have seen
it was he staring at you actually what
was said give me the story of that kind
of Infamous meme uh it was one of those
games just going back and forth very
very chirpy here and there but um he
definitely was staring at me and I'm
like yo like what you staring at and at
the end of the day like I feel like
the moment you you're staring with
someone and you move your eyes then they
they got you they won so I was like nah
he's not gonna just stare me down and I
and I lay down for it no that's not me
yeah you're like I'm not going back down
on that did y'all win the game yeah we
definitely wanted okay because I'm like
if you gonna stare you gotta go and win
the game absolutely absolutely a couple
more before we let you go you know
Dwyane Wade is such a big brother and
Mentor there's so many people in the
league I know that you all have a great
relationship when you're having
conversations with him about taking that
next step what words does he give you
um he just gives me that
I would say things that he gives me
would be just like feedback he gives me
a bunch of feedback on games to give me
a bunch of feedbacks on different plays
on things that I could have done better
I'm the type of person that I I enjoy
that I'd rather you tell me what I'm
doing wrong then I let me hear what I'm
doing right all the time and at the end
of the day with him he's not gonna
sugarcoat anything as you know D Wade's
one of those he's a legend and I'm
coming from a legend I'll take any any
advice there is so I just try to pick
and choose what I need to keep and pick
and choose what
um filter out the other things from it
but he's definitely one of those people
that I've always enjoyed having around
and so he's just a great person do you
have a favorite D Wade moment in his
career oh man
favorite I would say 21 Championship I
would say one Championship the first
time
um I feel like that was the most
meaningful just because it showed people
that like he can do it like at the end
of the day that's when it like it
clicked for me I don't know I feel like
that was just one of the most memorable
because he just took over for sure so
two years ago and it said Colin Sexton
has figured it out some time has passed
since then so now what would you say you
have figured out about your game in the
league
um how much I can impact uh the game
whether it's on defense or offense at
the end of the day I feel like I can
impact both ends of the floor and a lot
of times people can't really do that I
feel like I can change even without
having a ball just by my energy whenever
I step onto the court and that's
something that I carry with me like I
may not be able to make shots tonight
shots may not be falling I may be in
foul trouble but one thing I can control
is my energy and my in my effort I love
that okay you know I know we were
talking about the dunk contest is that
Trey Murphy over there sorry Murphy
gonna have to come up to the stage real
quick come on up Trey
give it up for Trey Murphy everybody
how are you Trey giving up for Colin
Sexton y'all are you about to make me
sit up here you're sitting Colin got up
so we will have you on the NBA Twitter
live show a little later yup yup so you
ready for that absolutely so I'm not
going to talk about everything here okay
but we are going to discuss that dunk
contest I need to say Trey Murphy had
some Elite Doug still jumping some very
very elite dunks that are kind of
getting lost in the sauce a little bit
tell me your favorite
um my favorite probably was the second
dunk that was the tomahawk windmill or
180 that one and uh
you know I wish I kind of had that one
back because I slipped a little bit on
the like on the way up there so I didn't
get as high as I wanted to but it still
turned out a pretty good look okay
okay really just you know getting down
five dunks that I wanted to do you know
just in case we went to an extra round
and
um just preparing for that that was
really what it was
so all-star weekend I don't know people
really understand how hectic how crazy
that it gets what's been your favorite
moment so far
um my favorite moment was probably you
know we had our Rising Stars give back
moment and uh we were packing backpacks
for kids and uh it was a really good
moment I got to get back to the
community and I really appreciate it a
lot so I know you have so many different
interests we see you kind of around your
doing some you know reporting yes it
looks like you've really enjoyed that
absolutely I give you I give you an A
plus but my last question is what if you
weren't an NBA player what would you be
doing
if I wasn't an NBA player I would
probably be a fashion designer
can we see fashion just
thank you
what about fashion that draws you in I
mean obviously what I'm wearing today is
well right now isn't the most
fashionable it's just a regular Nike
Tech but um I like expressing myself
through my clothes and I feel like I do
a pretty good job of that okay I love
that you all we will be on NBA Twitter
live a little later tonight so please
tune into that for the second half of
the game but thank you all for watching
for being here I enjoyed my time and
y'all have fun for the rest of us our
weekend and thank you so much Trey
Murphy thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign